-This is Kenan Thompson
right here.
That's who
we're hanging out with.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kenan.
-Me.
-That's you.
Dude, you're crushing it.
Congrats on the show.
-Thank you, man.
-Do your kids --
How old are your kids now?
7?
-They are 7 and 3,
my sweet little girls.
Georgia and Gianna.
-And do they know your stuff?
Do they know "good burger?"
Do they do know "SNL"?
-They know "SNL."
They're not supposed
to be up that late.
But they catch it the next day.
-Yeah, exactly.
-But I want them to find, like,
"Good Burger" and all that stuff
kind of organically.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want their friends in school
to be like,
"Y'all haven't seen
'Good Burger'?"
and let them, like, kind of
discover how awesome daddy was.
[ Laughter ]
-Or is.
I mean, dude, do they watch
"Kenan," and be like,
"Wait.
Dad, that's not your family."
-Yeah,
they get a little confused.
They're like, "So, wait.
Are they us, or are we them?"
[ Laughter ]
-Who is what?
Who is who?
-Only because they haven't met
because we started shooting
in the middle of a pandemic.
So, I mean, shout-out
to my cast and crew,
because we've been building
something pretty awesome
in some pretty dire situations.
You know?
-Yeah, thank you.
-I would send them
all the love in the world.
[ Applause ]
-I don't know
if I congratulated you
on getting nominated
for an Emmy for "Kenan."
Congratulations.
-Thank you, man.
Thank you, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Then got picked up, season two.
-It's been an incredible
roller coaster of a time, man.
Like, you know,
got nominated for that,
got nominated for "SNL,"
you know?
And it's just been
a very crazy time.
Like, People's Choice
was like a four piece.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah. Four piece.
-You know what I'm saying?
I'm nominated up.
-How do you get time
to film the show and do "SNL"?
-It's all under NBC,
and Lorne makes it happen.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, exactly.
-He just controls it all.
-But, I mean,
do you know where you are
right now?
-This is -- Who are you?
You are James Fallon.
-Yeah, James Fallon.
That's right.
I mean, we shoot, you know,
when "SNL" is off, kind of.
So we started in the summer,
and then "SNL" started,
so we took a break,
but then we only had, like,
a couple weeks to finish up,
so it overlapped a little bit.
-Must be tough to do a sitcom.
-At the beginning,
it was like a five-piece
back and forth,
so that was too much.
And, yeah, it's a big switch.
You know what I mean?
Like, going from sketch
to sitcom,
like going from thinking about
a million different ideas
to, like,
making a million different ideas
fit through one perspective.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, and having a plot.
-I didn't mean to get
super deep about acting.
-No, you should.
[ Laughter ]
This is your Master Class
on acting.
-Yeah, so, everybody buckle up.
The key
to character development...
-No, no, no!
We don't have time.
-...when you're thinking about
backstories...
-Season two, "Kenan,"
what do people have to know
if they hop into the show
Monday nights, on NBC?
-I think you need to know
that you can jump into the show
and have a laugh and not be lost
whenever you jump into it.
It doesn't matter.
Like, that was one of
the biggest goals
is to, like, get to the funny.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, we spent a lot of
the first season
explaining what it was,
and now we can
just explore these characters
and do whatever.
So whenever I, like,
watch a "Martin" marathon,
it doesn't matter, like,
what point of the episode
I catch it,
I just know, like,
for the rest of this time,
I'm gonna enjoy Martin Lawrence.
-There you go.
So that's the way to -- good way
to plug Martin Lawrence.
-Thanks. I got to bring
Martin Lawrence up.
-We're going from "Martin"
to "Kenan."
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kenan Thompson
in the new season of "Kenan."
Take a look at this.
-Kenan, Lawrence.
-Wow.
I was thinking, like,
maybe I deserve a little fun.
So I might be ready
to get on that app
and Impromptu Vous, too.
-Ooh, well, well, well!
Welcome to the Booty Dome!
-Keep your voice down.
-Dating app?
Why would you want the profile
of somebody that tells you
everything about them before you
even go out with them?
-Uh, so you know
what you're getting into,
like a movie trailer.
-Where's the fun in that?
You know what I say?
Just enjoy the ride.
-Sir, you -- you can't
just eat the produce.
-Real life, 1; the ride, zero!
-That's my man!
Kenan Thompson, everybody!
New episodes of "Kenan"
air Mondays at 8:00 p.m.
Every Monday
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.